- [Kim] Hi, this is Kim from Khan Academy.
Today, I'm learning about
the Eighth Amendment
to the US Constitution,
which prohibits the government
from imposing excessive fines and bail
or inflicting cruel and unusual punishment
on individuals accused
or convicted of a crime.
But what counts as excessive
or cruel and unusual?
To learn more, I sought out the help
of two experts on the Eighth Amendment.
John Stinneford is the assistant director
of The Criminal Justice Center
at the University of Florida Law School.
John Bessler is an
associate professor of law
at the University of Baltimore Law School.
So, Professor Bessler,
why were the Framers
so keen to include the Eighth Amendment?
Why did they wanna protect
these rights in particular?
- [Bessler] Well, these
rights were actually enshrined
in the English Bill of Rights of 1689.
And so when the Americans
got in the dispute with Great Britain,
they decided they wanted
to have the same rights
that Englishmen had.
And so it was not too surprising
that when George Mason actually wrote
the Virginia Declaration
of Rights in 1776,
that he looked to English law
to see what rights the English had
because he wanted exactly the same rights.
And so these 16 words
in the Eighth Amendment
have been subject to a lot of
controversy over the years.
But I think one of the reasons
that the Founders wanted this was that,
like the English would have problems
with the Monarch imposing
excessive bail, excessive fines,
inflicting cruel and unusual punishments,
the Founders also knew that was a risk
that there was abuse from the government
in the United States
and so they also wanted those rights.
Because originally in the Constitution,
these rights were not protected against.
And the Bill of Rights
was ratified in 1791
which ensured that there'd be protections
against these cruel
and unusual punishments
and excessive bail and excessive fines.
- [Stinneford] If you look
at the Eighth Amendment,
there's three clauses.
The excessive bail clause,
the excessive fines clause,
and the cruel and unusual
punishments clause.
And these all have one thing in common
which is that these are
all penalties essentially
that the government inflicts on people
usually as the result of
either being accused of crime
or of being convicted of crime.
So if you've been arrested,
you're waiting for trial,
very often your only way to
get out of jail before trial
is to make bail,
and of course after you've been convicted
the court might impose a fine on you
or some other kind of punishment.
So the Eighth Amendment is designed
to prevent the government
from doing things that are excessive.
When the government punishes a person,
that's the most coercive
thing the government does
short of war.
Other than shooting you in battle,
picking you up and
throwing you in a jail cell
is about as bad as it gets.
And so the Framers wanted to make sure
that we had a constitutional protection
when it comes to criminal punishment.
- [Kim] So, in a lot of
cases in the Bill of Rights,
you see the Framers reacting
to some historical evil
that they hoped to prevent.
For example, the Third Amendment says
you can't quarter soldiers
in private citizens homes
because that had been such
an important tipping point
in the American Revolution.
Was there something that
the Framers had in mind
as a particular historical evil
that they wanted to prevent?
- [Bessler] Well, there
was some historical evils.
The English Bill of Rights
went into place in 1689,
and when that went into place
it was actually a controversy in England
around a person by the
name of Titus Oates.
Titus Oates was somebody who
had made false accusations,
Oates had committed perjury,
resulted actually that allegation
in the execution of 15 Catholics.
And the plot that he had alleged
was one to assassinate
the King of England.
- [Stinneford] The question is
what to do with Oates, right?
Because as a moral matter,
he's about as bad as it gets.
In fact, in 2005, English
historians voted him
the worst Briton of the 17th century
and the third worst Briton
of the last thousand years
or something like that.
So a very bad guy.
You can think of him as
sort of a serial killer.
But the problem is that the
actual crime he committed
was the crime of perjury.
And even though his perjury
resulted in the deaths
of many innocent people,
nonetheless he could only
be convicted of perjury
which at the time was a misdemeanor,
which meant that he could not
be executed for his crime.
So when it came time for his sentencing,
the judge, Chief Justice Jeffreys,
who was a famous hanging
judge from English history,
says to Oates,
"Well, Oates, we can't take your life,
"we can't take your limb,
"but we have something
special prepared for you."
And it turns out that what
they had prepared for him was,
number one, a huge fine.
They fined him like 2,000 marks.
They sentenced that he be
dragged across the city of London
while being flogged.
He was dragged from Aldgate to
Newgate while being flogged.
And then two days later,
just as the scabs were
starting to form on his wounds,
he's dragged back across
the city of London
from Newgate to Tyburn
again while being flogged.
Many people think the hope was
that he would die from the flogging
but, like a cockroach in a
nuclear war, he survived.
- [Bessler] This punishment
was actually a very severe punishment.
And after the English Bill
of Rights was promulgated,
the Titus Oates punishment was challenged.
And some of the members
of the House of Lords
actually called the punishment barbarous,
inhuman and unchristian
and contrary to the
English Bill of Rights.
So there was no precedent to warrant
the punishments of whipping
and committing to prison for life
for the crime of perjury.
This punishment was eventually remitted
in the sense that Oates
was later released.
- [Stinneford] Although the House of Lords
refused to vote to suspend
the judgment against Oates
'cause they hated his so much.
They said so ill a man
shouldn't get the benefit of any relief.
But they all agreed
that the punishment was cruel and unusual.
And what's interesting is
in the debate they say things like,
this punishment is contrary
to law and ancient practice.
It is without precedent
and it'll be a bad
precedent for the future.
So, in other words, it's cruel,
and the way we know it's cruel
is because it's so much harsher
than has previously been inflicted
for the crime of perjury.
So the Oates case shows us
that when the words cruel
and unusual were first used,
they were used to describe punishments
that are harsher than the
common law would permit,
or harsher than longstanding
prior practice would permit.
And this means, among other things,
that the cruel and
unusual punishments clause
is not limited to gruesome punishments
like torture and the rack
and all that kind of thing.
'Cause in fact the punishments
inflicted on Oates,
although they were very harsh
for the crime of perjury,
were not as harsh as
some other punishments
that the common law permitted
for other crimes like treason.
- [Kim] Wow.
So that tells us a lot
about the English context
of cruel and unusual punishment.
Do we know what cruel and unusual meant
to the Framers of the US Bill of Rights?
- [Stinneford] Punishments
were cruel and unusual, again,
if they're too harsh
in light of longstanding prior practice
for the crime for which they're inflicted.
There's another problem with statutory law
or with decisions of a judge or a king,
or a president for that matter,
that's also really relevant
when we think about the
Eighth Amendment and that is
sometimes the government
gets really mad at someone.
They either think of a person
as an enemy of the state
and they wanna inflict the
worst punishment they can
on that person,
or perhaps there's a panic about
a certain group in society.
For example, in American society recently,
there have been panics about drug crime
or panics about sex offenses.
And every time that happens
the government tries to respond
with new forms of punishment
that are much, much harsher
than what came before.
So the insight behind
the Eighth Amendment is
that when the government wants
to inflict a new punishment,
you have to compare it against
longstanding prior practice,
that is you have to compare
it against the common law.
So the common law was called
the law of custom and long usage.
So if something comported
with the common law,
it was usual.
If it was contrary to the common law,
it was unusual.
And that's where we get the phrase
cruel and unusual punishments.
It's basically punishments that are cruel
in light of or in comparison to
longstanding prior practice.
So the basic point of the Eighth Amendment
from a historical point of view
is to prohibit the government
from innovating in a cruel manner,
making up new cruel punishments
in response to some actual
or perceived provocation
by a criminal.
- [Bessler] When the US
Bill of Rights was adopted
many years later, many decades later,
they had their own issues that
they were struggling with.
And so the history shows
that the American Founders
probably meant something
different than the English meant
because it was done
over a 100 years later,
but no one knows exactly what was meant
when they adopted that wording.
To give an example,
when the Bill was debated in Congress,
a representative from South Carolina
said that he objected to the words
nor cruel and unusual punishments
because he said the import
of them was too indefinite.
And there was another legislator,
Mr. Livermore from New Hampshire,
who said that the clause seemed to express
"A great deal of humanity,
"in which account I
have no objection to it.
"But as it seems to have no meaning in it,
"I do not think it necessary.
"What is meant by the
terms excessive bail?"
He asked.
"Who are to be the judges?"
He also asked.
"What is understood by excessive fines?"
It lies to the court to determine.
And so that's really where we
are today in a lot of ways.
The court is still deciding,
in this case the US Supreme
Court is still deciding
what the Eighth Amendment
language actually means today.
- [Stinneford] The modern case law,
specially starting in the 1970s,
revolved a lot around the death penalty.
And so the question was,
is it still okay to execute people
for various crimes short of murder?
Since the 70s,
the Court has continued to
do that in a number of areas.
So it's said
you can't execute the
mentally disabled anymore,
you can't execute minors,
you can't execute anyone
for a non-homicide offense.
Although it's limited the death penalty
in the name of current
standards of decency,
it's really not clear how
the Court has set about
to determine whether a punishment
meets current standards of decency.
When the Court is kind of on its own
saying that a punishment
violates current standards of decency,
despite the fact
that most democratically
elected legislators
actually approve the practice,
then it looks like the Court
is acting as a political body.
It's led the court to ignore
what I think is the
real danger of cruelty,
which is that when there's a public panic
and the legislature responds
by rationing up punishment
to new and unprecedented
levels of punishment.
And that's actually happened quite a lot
in the last 40 years.
Every time there's a panic,
you predictably see the legislatures
coming up with new punishments
that are much, much harsher
than what came before.
And so for example with sex offenders,
there are now a bunch of states
that actually impose chemical castration
as a form of punishment for sex offenders.
Now, castration as a form of punishment
fell out of usage in the 13th century.
We're literally getting
medieval on sex offenders.
But the Court can't do
anything really to stop it,
or at least hasn't,
because these are very
popular forms of punishment.
Everyone hates sex offenders.
- [Bessler] The UN has actually decided
that anything more than 15-days
use of solitary confinement
should not be permitted.
Justice Anthony Kennedy
actually raised the issue
of solitary confinement
in recent opinion.
He authored for the Supreme Court
and he actually raised
the issue on his own,
an oral argument at one point,
talking about how long
people actually spend
in solitary confinement
in American prisons,
including on death row.
You have cases actually
where people are spending
not just years but sometimes
decades on death row
in these kinds of conditions.
Justice Breyer just
wrote a dissent in a case
where the person had been on death row
for more than 40 years,
so literally four decades
in these kinds of very harsh
conditions of confinement.
Other countries have decided
that that is not something
that they want to permit
and they've actually set a rule
that anybody that's on death row
for a certain number of years for example
would have their sentence
commuted to a life sentence
because of the psychological aspect
of waiting for one's own death.
- [Kim] In the Bill of Rights,
this is the last of four
amendments, actually,
that are concerned with
protections for the accused.
So, why do you think there is
so much in the Bill of Rights
about the justice system?
Were the Framers particularly interested
in making sure that
the accused had rights?
- [Stinneford] Yeah, they were.
And in particular
Americans were very devoted
to the idea of the common
law as a source of rights.
In fact, that's why we had
the American Revolution
in the first place,
was that England was denying
to Americans common law rights
like the right not to be taxed
without representation in Parliament
but also more specifically
to the criminal law
they were denying them
the right to a jury trial
in criminal cases.
And so Americans wanted to make sure
that when the US Constitution was adopted
that those common law rights
that had built up over time in England
would be preserved in the new
American constitutional order.
And many of those rights
had to do with criminal law,
both criminal procedures
and to some degree
subsequence of criminal law
and of course criminal punishments.
And, again, the reason gets back
to what I said at the beginning
which is that when the
government punishes someone,
that's about the worse thing it can do.
And because the early Americans
who framed the Constitution
were very powerfully
concerned with liberty,
they wanted to make sure
the government would
preserve their liberty,
protect their liberty,
and not become tyrannical.
And so one of the main ways
that they wanted to
make sure this happened
was by limiting the
power of the government
to punish whoever it wanted to
for any reason that it wanted to.
And so we have really the
majority of the protections
in the Bill of Rights
have to do with the protections
for criminal defendants.
- [Kim] What about excessive
bail and excessive fines?
How can we define what
kind of financial penalty
is proportionate to a crime?
- [Bessler] The courts
have said, essentially,
they've looked at dictionary definitions,
that excessive means
more than it's necessary.
One of the core principles
actually go back to look at
Beccaria's work in the 1760s.
He talked about this
idea of a scale of crimes
and a scale of punishments,
and he said that there
should be proportionality
between the two.
And so that proportionality principle
is one that we're really
still wrestling with today.
- [Stinneford] Now, the point of bail
is not to punish someone
but rather just to make sure
that they will appear at trial.
And so the amount of money
you have to impose for bail
doesn't depend so much on
what crime you committed
but what your financial resources are.
It depends partially on the crime too
but largely on your financial resources.
So the amount of money necessary
to make sure that a poor
man appears at trial
is probably gonna be much lower
than the amount of money necessary
to make sure that a rich
man appears at trial.
And so it's a standard
that depends partly on
the nature of the crime
but also partially on the
nature of the offender.
- [Kim] I imagine that what seemed
like cruel and unusual
punishment in the 18th century
might not be what we consider
cruel and unusual today.
For example, we don't do
whipping as a punishment anymore.
How has what counts as
cruel and unusual punishment
changed over time?
- [Bessler] The law really
changes gradually over time,
as you know.
And so when you look back at history,
they actually had a large collection
of pretty gruesome punishments
back in the 18th century.
We had non-lethal corporal punishments,
they used things like branding people.
They of course were
whipping slaves back then.
Slavery was still around.
This is well before the Civil War ended
and the destitution of slavery.
And we also had things like ear cropping.
People would get their ears cut off.
In the Crimes Act of 1790,
which was passed just the year before
the ratification of the Eighth Amendment,
Congress actually
authorized public whipping,
lashing of people,
and it also authorized the pillory,
the same punishment that had
been used against Titus Oates.
So there was these non-lethal
corporal punishments
and really the death penalty
is the last vestige of bodily punishment
that the Supreme Court has
read the Eighth Amendment
to allow the use of capital punishment.
That issue is still a very live one
before the Supreme Court,
renouncing challenges about
lethal injection protocols.
We saw a challenge to a
protocol in Kentucky in 2008.
We saw one to protocol
in Oklahoma in 2015.
These of course are things
that the Founding Fathers
would never have envisioned.
- [Stinneford] Lethal injection
typically involves a three-drug cocktail.
There's a barbiturate which is
supposed to put you to sleep.
There's a paralyzing agent
which paralyzes your body
and also stops your lungs from moving.
And there's a heart-stopping agent.
Give the offender all three
and they're supposed to
die quickly and painlessly.
But the problem is,
if the sedative doesn't put you
completely, deeply unconscious,
then the other two drugs
are likely to make you suffer
quite a bit before you die.
And so the question is,
is this cruel and unusual or
is it not cruel and unusual?
And to date the Supreme
Court has twice held
that lethal injection
is not cruel and unusual
and their main reason has been
that the state's not trying
to torture you to death
and so if maybe
you're sometimes accidentally
tortured to death
well, that's just too bad,
but it's not a cruel
and unusual punishment.
- [Bessler] So the (mumbles) has approved
various methods of execution.
At the same time, however,
the Eighth Amendment has been
read to protect prisoners.
So in general the Eighth Amendment
is sort of a protective shield
that prohibits prison guards
from gratuitously beating up inmates.
It requires prisons to provide
some level of health care to prisoners
because they cannot get it themselves,
they are sort of wards of the state
once they're put in prison.
It requires inmates be fed and sheltered.
So in a lot of ways
the Eighth Amendment
is a protective shield
protecting inmates,
but then in the use of
the capital punishment
it becomes what I like to call,
it's kind of a Dr. Jekyll
and Mr. Hyde jurisprudence
that the Eighth Amendment has right now.
- [Kim] So, we've learned
that the Eighth Amendment
seeks to limit the power of the government
in meeting out punishment to people
who have been accused
or convicted of a crime.
Although it's hard to tell
exactly what constitutes
excessive fines or bail,
in general it's accepted
that those punishments
should be proportional to
the crimes in question.
Today, one of the biggest debates
concerns whether or how
the Eighth Amendment
may limit the death penalty.
To learn more about the Eighth Amendment,
visit the National Constitution Center's
Interactive Constitution
and Khan Academy's resources
on US government and politics.